we have the president of the european
council standing here and the president
of the european commission you know we
have translation we'll have
q a following the president's
interventions first
please thank you and
good evening everyone before discussing
kavit 19
i'd like to give you a brief update
on the mff as you know in july we agreed
by unanimity
the mff and recovery package and
we need to stay united on this this
financial package
is essential for our economic recovery
we need to implement it as soon as
possible
chancellor merkel gave us an update on
the state of play
of the ongoing discussion following the
last twilight with parliament
on the mechanism unconditionality the
vast majority of member states agree
with a compromise on the table and some
member states have
indicated that they are not able to
support the majority
we will continue the discussions to find
an acceptable solution to all
on terrorism we expressed our solidarity
towards france and austria we will never
shy away
from defending our values and promoting
our freedoms
and we will continue to fight the
ideology
of hatred including online
it's crucial for us to look at the role
of online platforms
and set a stricter framework we will
look
at this issue together in december and
look forward
with to the commission's proposal on
this the digital services act
which we expect in december covet 19
in europe remains serious and concerning
and we are monitoring the situation
closely that's why today
we continued our discussions to assess
the current situation
and coordinate our efforts we have seen
promising signs since our last meeting
but we remain cautious and vigilant
we cannot let down our guard we
discussed again three important
issues testing vaccines and the lifting
of restrictive measures and coordination
first on testing
we discussed how to develop a common eu
approach
for the use of rapid antigen tests
those states those tests are coming
complementary to pcr tests
in our testing strategies we need to
work
towards mutual recognition of tests and
the results
for rapid tests this is based on common
criteria
guaranteeing their performance we also
discussed
national testing strategies and exchange
best practices
students on vaccines the results of
recent trials are
encouraging future vaccines are within
which
and we need to be ready we agreed to
speed up the preparations of national
vaccination plans
to ensure vaccines are available and
affordable to all european citizens
once authorized we welcome that member
states and the commission
have already finalized several purchases
agreements
there will be we know that logistical
challenges
like storage transport and the number of
doses
and another challenge will be
communication
the number of people distrustful
of vaccines is growing and we must
clearly communicate their value
finally we had a discussion
on the lifting of restrictions we need
to learn
past lessons and be cautious when
we lift restrictions it should be
gradual
and regressive we all
want to celebrate the end of the year
holidays
but safely let's reach in the new year
safely covet 19
has a devastating human cost there are
family
and friends behind all the numbers and
statistics
let's never forget that that's why
we are working 24 7 to defeat this virus
let's continue to stand together work
together
and support each other we will follow up
at our next european council meeting in
december
thank you mr president madam president
you have a floor yes thank you very much
so indeed this vtc was mostly about
covet and it has an enormous
added value that we have a coordination
to
what our response to the covet
pandemic is concert across the eu in
this context
i could announce that we had the first
meeting
of the eu platform of national science
advisors that took place last week it
was a very good meeting
and we have agreed that we will have
every two weeks now
this platform meeting of the national
science and health advisors to the
government
in order to have a benchmarking and to
have an exchange of
best practices and experience another
topic was
the passenger locator form here
i can update that four weeks ago we were
tasks to develop a passenger locator
form
digitally now we are launching the first
pilot uh in close cooperation with eyaza
and the good news is that two member
states now have already
signed up this is enough to start the
pilot
but we have another 12 member states
that are now technically ready to join
because
they have already adopted a compatible
digital passenger locator form so our
goal is
that we will be ready with
the passenger locator form till the end
of the year
the tests of course were a big topic
as you know yesterday the commission has
adopted a recommendation on the use
of rapid antigen tests this was the
topic
of course in the vtc on when to use them
and how to use them
here's important the rapid antigen tests
are good if you have a high prevalence
of infected people of the virus
of course the gold standard is always
the pcr
but the pcrs are way more expensive
and they need laboratory capacity so it
lasts longer till the result is there
and therefore the rapid antigen tests
are very interesting
for example to manage outbreaks or
to regularly monitor high-risk groups
for example in admission to healthcare
facilities
but also for the triage of symptomatic
patients or residents
important is that we
set performance criterias because at the
moment being you see that a lot of
rabbit antigen tests are appearing on
the market
and not all of them have the same
quality so it is important
to have rapid antigen tests that
have a sensitivity that is above
80 percent that means if you have
100 of uh infected people
the test has at least to discover
more than 80 of these or if you
would like to prefer smaller numbers if
you have five infected people
at least four should be detected by the
rapid antigen test
then it has a good performance why i'm
saying that because there are so many
different on the market
it is for us important that we validate
and therefore we establish
a eu framework for the validation and
this of course brings then
mutual recognition across border
the vaccination topic was also of high
importance
we have now adopted five contracts
with biontech kurovac astrazeneca j
johnson johnson and sanofi and we
continue
negotiations with moderna and we are in
talk
talks with novavax it was very good to
see that
all member states have signed up to buy
all the same vaccines and stay in our
portfolio that is good news
this portfolio of now five vaccines
hopefully soon six
vaccines types is so important because
it covers four different technologies
to produce a vaccine and it may be
so that different vaccines work better
in different parts of their populations
than other
of course all vaccines in our portfolio
will be properly assessed
with all data by ema the european
medicine
agency before we authorize them
for us is very important to be in close
contact with other renowned
authorities for example when we come
to the authorization of biontech or
moderna
to be in close cooperation on contact
with the fda the u.s
equivalent to our ema emma is in daily
calls
with the fda to synchronize the
assessment
and if all proceeds with no
problems emma tells us
that the conditional marketing
authorization
for biontech and moderna could happen as
early as
the second half of december 2020.
to the international part kovacs
you know the international facility to
make sure that low and middle income
countries have access
to vaccine to vaccines here
the team europe that is the member
states and
the european commission provided 800
million euro to covax
this is the largest donation in the
world
and this is a very good message
of the team europe last but not least
we have all learned from the experience
in the summer that
the exit from a wave in this case the
exit from the first wave
is very difficult and that the impact of
lifting measures
too hasty has had a
a very bad impact on the epidemiological
situation in summer
and fall therefore this time
expectations have to be managed
we will make a proposal for a gradual
and coordinated approach to lifting
coordination
containment measures this will
be very important to avoid the risk
of yet another wave and we are working
on a vaccination campaign to support
member states in the communication
on the importance of vaccines
it is self-protection and it is
solidarity
finally indeed the president of the
council already
said that there was a brief exchange on
mff next generation eu and the
conditionality
mechanism we had found an agreement in
july
at 27 it consists of these
three components i think to meet the
needs and expectations of the european
citizens
we need the whole package it has been
agreed between the council and the
european parliament
now it is important that we move
forward the commission supports the
agreement found
in the trial between council and
parliament
and for me it is equally important for
the future of the european union
to have a budget and to uphold the rule
of law
we are now working with the rotation
rotating presidency
who is leading the efforts to find a
solution
we all know that millions of european
businesses and citizens
are waiting for the answer in the midst
of
this unprecedented crisis and the
strength of our
union has always been to overcome
difficult situation
by engaging with each other so we
continue
to work hard to reach an agreement soon
thank you
thank you madam president we'll take a
few questions now we have many
so we won't be able to talk to all of
you can i
ask you kindly to switch on your cameras
and and please stay to whom you want to
address your question to
we'll take uh oliver grimm first from uh
depressor
depressor oliver can you hear us
is
[Music]
no it was not topic in this vtc
in general we all know that
vaccination is a matter of safety and
trust
and we only have safety and trust if
there is transparency
about the data of the development of the
vaccine
and how the clinical trials have been
have been conducted and therefore i
think
it is of utmost importance that
any vaccine that should be used should
undergo
the authorization process in emma this
is then full transparency
this creates trust and this makes sure
that
safety is guaranteed this is my opinion
on this case
next question is for susanna susana
freshes
please susana can you hear us yeah yeah
thank you
susannah hic and
portugal still on vaccines i would like
to ask
president you mentioned that uh a green
light could happen in the second half of
december for two vaccines so should we
expect a
distribution already in december or
something only in january
and which which chair do we expect um
to say for third countries did the
leaders
have agreed on this and if i may also
on the mff should we expect a physical
meeting
here in brussels in december to discuss
this topic and how do you expect to
solve its political declaration
or a recovery fund without these two
countries thank you
[Music]
a
thank you on the vaccines so
i wanted to reiterate that emma tells us
that conditional marketing authorization
so this is the
very very first step to be able to go on
the market for biotech and moderna
could happen as early as the second half
of december
if all proceeds now without any
problem so then of course at the
beginning
small numbers come and the large numbers
will only come later this is important
to keep in mind
this also explains why we had asked
the member states that based on our
blueprint from the commission
they please develop vaccination plans
so the recommendation is for example
first health care workers and essential
workers
the elderly people with comorbidity
so that there is a clear planning and
explanation
that you have a stepwise approach
approach as the doses come for the
vaccination
on the other question with the
neighborhood
there is a two-fold approach
the most important and impressive one
is kovacs that we have created
together internationally with the help
of many many
i think about 190
countries are now member of kovacs and
the principle is that the high-income
country
make sure that they fund kovacs in order
to give the possibility to the low and
middle-income countries
to have access to vaccines gavi
is the overall organizat the overall
organization
authority in the corvex facility and
there is another option
that if member states happen to have
too many doses they of course
are able and legally
allowed to donate those doses for
example for
the western balkan as at the moment
being
the different vaccines that are being
developed in the european portfolio
are promising so far we had no failure
it may as uh very well be that we
reached this stage i was just describing
thank you we'll take another question
now from deutsche welle
bernt riegertz parents
you have the flow yes thank you very
much
a question to both presidents
how do you see the actions by poland and
hungary
do you feel betrayed or blackmailed
okay it's not
my intention to say anything which
would make the situation more more
difficult
the situation is the following in july
we we took a very important decision and
i think just a
group a right an important step in the
right
direction and now we need to implement
what we have decided
uh and that's why the german presidency
uh
sweat where we heart with the european
parliament with the support of the
commission
in order to to make a deal with the
european parliament
uh we take note of the current situation
but it's not enough we are working and
we will continue to to work
in order to find a solution uh i think
like we we said before
that it's key for our people
everywhere in europe it's key for our
businesses the small
uh the the medium size and
to demonstrate uh that we are able to to
support
a very strong recovery effort a very
strong recovery
package we have a clear vision about
what we need to do in the future we need
to improve and to strengthen our climate
ambition we need to
develop our digital agenda we need
financial means
we took a very important and strong
decision
a few months ago and now we need to
implement what we have
decided and we will work in order to
reach this goal
yes basically my answer is very clear
neither nor this cannot be
indeed we have a very serious situation
now
people in europe and the businesses
the companies in europe are urgently
waiting
for the funding in this unprecedented
crisis and deep recession
coming from next generation eu and
indeed now
we sit down we negotiate we listen to
what the issues are we try to solve them
and again i want to reiterate that
europe and many many very critical
situations in the very end has found
solutions to move forward
thank you i will take one last question
de france van catre
catherine nicholson catherine
hi there yes on a similar note
i'm talking about the uh mff uh you said
uh michelle that there was a compromise
on the table can you tell us more about
what this compromise
involves and you also said that the vast
majority of member states
agree on the conditionality can you tell
us which member states
did not agree i i'm convinced that
you you know which are the member states
uh which have expressed uh uh doubts on
the compromise
on the compromise which is uh on the on
the table
but to be to be clear uh i received
ursula angela merkel and myself
let us form from three countries
expressing uh reserves on the
current compromise which is on the table
and i think that we need to
to work very hard in order to try to to
find the solution
madam president maybe you okay we're
fine
okay that's fine all encompassing thank
you thank you for your
interventions thank you for joining us
and see you next time
[Music]
you